[Music]
in this video we will learn how to
troubleshoot and resolve an unhealthy
load balancer back-end
google cloud offers a variety of load
balancing options such as
http proxy load balancing tcp ssl proxy
load balancing and even tcp udp pass
reload balancing
troubleshooting load balancer back-ends
uses the same methodology irrespective
of the load bouncer type
before diving into troubleshooting an
unhealthy backhand let's understand some
concepts
first up what does an unhealthy backend
mean
it means a health check probe is
configured on the load balancer to the
back end are failing
so what are health check probes
health checks are tests that enable load
balancers to confirm if the back end is
available to serve traffic or not
connection requests are sent to backends
on a configurable periodic basis
each connection attempt is called a
probe
google cloud records the success or
failure of each probe and marks the
back-ends as healthy or unhealthy
let's now understand what is the success
criteria for health checks
google cloud supports several protocols
for the health check like tcp http https
grpc
the success criteria for health checks
varies depending on the protocol being
used for tcp the health check probe
needs to successfully establish a tcp
connection with the backend on the
specified port
while for http and https the healthcheck
probe needs to successfully receive a
200 http response from the backend on
the specified url
we'll now dive into a demo to learn how
to troubleshoot and resolve an unhealthy
backend
in the google cloud console go to
network services load balancing page
and click on your load bouncer
in our example we will select web map
http
as we can see it has an unhealthy back
end
looking at its health check we see the
health check is using http protocol and
probing on port 80.
if your health checkport mentions
serving port then the port being health
checked is a network endpoint group or
neg port
the load balancer has marked the back
end as unhealthy possibly due to a lack
of response for the http probe from the
back end to investigate this further
let's ssh into the unhealthy backend and
verify for processes listening on the
configured health check port by using
the netstat command
there you go the process listens on this
port if you don't have netstat you can
try using netcat as follows
if a process is listening it will show
an output similar to this if not it will
show connection refused
we've successfully found that there is a
process listening on the health check
pull up
next step is to create a health check
probe and see if it is successful or not
in this example we're using http
protocol so we can test the health check
by running the curl command
we're getting a 200 ok response this
indicates that the health check probes
are successfully passing locally on the
backend instance
however the health check probes from
load balancer are failing this could
most likely be due to a firewall
misconfiguration
one of the ways to verify firewalls are
properly configured is to use tcp dump
and capture packets
first determine the health check source
ranges which the probes will be using
for your load bouncer type you can find
this information from this documentation
you can install tcp dump using a package
management system like apt
capture the packets received from the
health check ranges by running this
command on the unhealthy backend
there are no incoming packets
this clearly indicates that the firewall
is not configured to allow ingress from
the healthtrack probe ranges to the
healthcheck port
perhaps getting blocked in the implicit
block all ingress firewall rule
to fix this issue create the firewall
rule to ensure that the traffic is
allowed from the health check probe
ranges to the health check port
first let's go back to the console and
go to vpc network firewall
create firewall rule
allow ingress to your back-ends by
specifying their targets tags service
accounts or just all instances in the
network
configure the source ranges to the
health check ranges used for load
balancer type you're using this is an
http load bouncer so i'll use these two
ranges
phew we now see incoming packets from
the health check ranges
go back to load balancer page
congratulations the backend is now
healthy
for more information on troubleshooting
unhealthy backends check out this
documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]